this is just gross but probably not a
shock
Republicans are defending Donald Trump
Supreme Court pick Brett Kavanaugh
against the sexual assault allegations
that are plaguing him at this point not
by saying he didn't do it but by saying
that if he did it it really shouldn't
matter that much because it was a long
time ago anyway and of course this
ignores the fact that if he did it even
a long time ago he's still actively
lying about it now so the question is
are you saying that we should ignore
both that he assaulted someone a long
time ago and that he's lying about it
today or are you saying that we simply
don't know what it is that happened
because those are two very very
different positions for Republicans
potentially to take and then more
importantly who believes that it
shouldn't matter because it happened a
long time ago legally yes we have
something called the statute of
limitations that may have passed based
on the alleged acts that took place but
if I told you hey I've got a great
babysitter for you she did steal from a
family she babysat from once but it was
a long time ago and the police weren't
called anyway so it's not like she was
ever actually charged with a crime do
you ignore that and you say well listen
it happened a long time ago I'm glad to
hire her to babysit my kids today or do
you say no we it doesn't matter that
legally she's not going to get in
trouble I'm not hiring her as my
babysitter I think most of you know the
answer and this by the way isn't hiring
somebody for one night it's giving
somebody a job for life Republicans are
okay with the boys will be boys type of
thinking the locker room talk to take a
phrase out of Donald Trump's vocabulary
silly attempted rape that failed anyway
I mean come on hormones and stuff right
attempted rape only matters for Supreme
Court candidates if they did it recently
like is that actually the position that
these Republicans are taking and there
was a time I know it's hard to remember
now because of where we are there was
actually a time when Republicans had bad
economic eye
but they were it totally failed people
as individuals they are now genuinely
hypocritical bigots who value ignorance
and value anti-intellectualism
over morality and some semblance of
intelligence and critical thinking and
this doesn't even really appear to come
down to whether Republicans are willing
to accept Cavanaugh's lies and put them
on the court anyway this actually
violates the rules of integrity for
judges and for lawyers these rules vary
from state to state and from federal to
state and depending on the body that
you're talking about and of course these
are guidelines it's not the law but some
version of a rule that says if as a
lawyer or a judge you engage in conduct
involving dishonesty fraud deceit
misrepresentation or the appearance
thereof you are not fit to serve period
this is super cut and dry
you don't even actually have to
adjudicate the sexual assault
allegations because of the other lies
but in total there are two possible
answers here this is like
multiple-choice it's very binary either
their position is that it's okay for
Brett Kavanaugh to lie previously and
possibly now and just make them a judge
for life anyway or you have to take the
position that lying is not okay and that
lying under oath is not okay and it's
illegal and you shouldn't appoint such a
person to the Supreme Court period and
even if you want to defend Brett
Cavanaugh's actions when he was in high
school or you want to say well listen at
the time it was a long time ago we don't
know exactly what happened and even if
he did it his brain wasn't fully formed
in the hormones you can defend the
actions as a high schooler legally and
say we're gonna let it go
legally statute of limitations of course
having expired anyway but you don't have
to put the guy on the Supreme Court for
life and make him one of the nine
highest judges in the land and we're
quickly learning that this is one of the
most despicable nominees to the court in
decades and also I don't know if you saw
this but Brett
Cavanaugh put out a really strange
statement saying that he wasn't at that
party
how does Cavanaugh know that he wasn't
at the party at which supposedly
Christine Blasi Ford was the subject of
an attempted rape how does he know which
party that would be if he wasn't at the
party like is he saying I didn't go to
any pool parties anywhere that entire
year that's how I'm sure or is he aware
that there was an alleged rape at a
particular party but he's claiming he
wasn't they like it's the weirdest way
to try to exculpate yourself the excuses
don't work whatsoever and it's weird
because this is maybe something that
Cavanaugh could get beyond because he
was under the age of 18 and you know
many people understand that people in
their youth make mistakes certainly
doesn't excuse it but he could still be
nominated and appointed and approved to
the Supreme Court despite that but you
have to tell your story and you have to
be straight with it you can't get away
with all these lies no and this
statement it reminds me of mr. Cavanaugh
do you know who killed this man
officer I have no idea who strangled
that guy to death strangled mr.
Cavanaugh I asked if you knew who killed
him I didn't mention anything about a
strangulation how do you know that he
was strangled right no no no I had
nothing to do with it and I wasn't at
the party at which she was attempted
were at which she suffered an attempted
rape very strange way to defend yourself
and maybe we'll learn more about it at
some point
today's episode is made possible in part
by better help.com slash Pakman I've
spoken about the unfair and unfortunate
stigma that there can be around therapy
there shouldn't be and better help makes
things even easier for you if you've
been thinking about getting involved and
working with a therapist you get access
to fully licensed experienced
psychologists and therapists through
your phone or computer all you have to
do is go to better help calm slash
Pakman you fill out a questionnaire they
match you with a counselor that'll work
best for you you can ask if you want
that your therapist not be religious if
that is important to you and at any
point if you think your therapist is not
a good fit you can switch and work with
somebody else it's less expensive
than seeing a counselor in person but
better help also gives you unlimited
access to your counsel you can talk to
them every day if you want you will not
get that with an in-person therapist so
go to better help calm slash Pakman so
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the video description if
you're watching on YouTube check it out
better help calm slash PA que ma N